abortion is once again legal in Iowa
just two days after an abortion ban at
six weeks was signed into law a judge
has just struck down these restrictions
and I really should call them
protections because they're protections
of The Unborn and abortion is now legal
up to 20 weeks in Iowa yeah Iowa's a
really interesting case because you're
seeing this live battle play out I mean
when Governor Kim Reynolds went to sign
this new legislation which successfully
pass the Republican held house after a
special session
there was a judge saying you know I am
actively in the middle of a challenge on
this and I can't it would be flippant of
me to rule on this without giving it
consideration so that law went into
effect on Friday and he came out early
this week and said you know actually we
can't go forward with this we're going
to revert back to our 20-week ban on
abortion uh Kim the legislation in
question is a six-week ban there are
certain exceptions for rape and princess
a fetal viability if it's in question or
if it's it they couldn't survive outside
the womb and mother's health what I find
interesting is you're seeing Iowa itself
split apart and of course for us I was
significant because it's an early
primary State uh what happens in Iowa
especially during elections cycle is
often viewed as a magnifying glass on
the rest of the country yeah no I agree
and I think we're going to see a lot
more of this there's going to be a
massive Clash there I'm curious to hear
your perspective on this once again as
somebody coming over here from England
what are the laws and social conventions
like surrounding abortion one thing you
hear all the time from American
progressives is that we are just this
backwards far-right Theocratic Nation
relative to the enlightened Europeans
who just let anything that the
progressives want happen but especially
prior to row if you actually looked at
abortion laws in Europe you would find
that many of them were actually more
strict than the laws that you would have
especially in blue states in the U.S
I am sorry to rain on your parade a
little bit
um that's not the case in how it plays
out in England so in oh no the English
case is legally it's 24 weeks to spot
other than if you can have a health
example that can justify it going
further and can I just interject us one
question yes when you say health example
so in the United States like like for
example there are certain blue states
where like up until the point of birth
which is why I'm saying that it that's
so much harsher than what you have in
Europe but what I want to ask you about
with this legal exception for the case
of the life of the mother one thing that
happens in the U.S is they will use
things like depression or a poor mental
health outcome to justify that is it the
same it's exactly the same in England
yeah that we we have far fewer abortions
in the United States
um as a proportion of population as well
but it still does happen and abortion in
the UK is unfortunately one of those
things that's just declared Beyond
reproach I was once once called um
anti-english because I was against
abortion because it's just been settled
law for for how long anti-english huh
yeah and I want English babies aborted
yeah I know yeah radical position I
suppose um one of the disturbing things
that's happened and this has happened
um both because of the rising prominence
in the polls of the labor party after
their stinking defeat in 2019 they're
now getting a bit more bold because they
know they're probably going to win the
next election anyway and after the
unaids principles which I don't know if
you guys know about no okay I'll explain
that in a minute because it's a pretty
dark Rabbit Hole um but we recently had
a debate in Parliament um among the MPS
this isn't tabled legislation yet but
about a right to an abortion in a
British Bill of Rights that is being
drafted after brexit and Stella Creasy
who is a labor MP she sits on the the
women's Council she had gone from I
think it was two years ago bringing her
infant into the House of Commons even
though they have daycare which I'm
against
um but she could have put it in the
crash in time she made a deliberate
point to bring the baby in went from
that to arguing to no restrictions on
abortion and a right to abortion
codified within the British Bill of
Rights in law and so they're getting
pretty bold for that um and one of the
reasons I think this is the case is
because the UN on International women's
day this March put out their 21 AIDS
principles to govern
um Sexual Health Drug law things like
that and among these things were
um abortion up until the point of birth
has absolutely no restrictions for all
member states
um Downstream from that it was the
decriminalization of all drugs including
uh who was the fellow from launch from
was it launched from the Surfs yeah yeah
um that's the un's position now you
should be able to take drugs and suffer
no penalties while you're pregnant
um all gender affirming care for all
ages and they also said that there are
some cases where children may be mature
enough to consent disgusting yes and
disgusting yeah and and so this is
something that is coming for most
countries probably in Europe as well
um that's the case in the UK how does
British law work like uh if you're
talking about like York Northumberland
do they have their own sets of Rights
like state rights no no no it's all
centralized it's it's just Nationals is
that also like federal police everywhere
like yeah yeah so we have we have the
Met police in London um who operate from
a slightly different commissioner I
think each each area has Commissioners
but we can like Central to the
government they can set General policing
law the police in England are mad as
well I nearly got arrested last year
outside of to Party Conference there was
a video that did did the rounds what
ended up happening was
um I went outside to film a Street
Preacher who was arguing with some young
girls who were arguing in favor of
abortion just outside the secure Zone
and I was filming it and a local
journalist came up to me and said what
do you think of this and I just arrived
on scene what's even happening and she
said this gentleman here is saying that
the lgbtq plus Community are unnatural
according to scripture and I said right
well I haven't heard any of this but you
know I've just been speaking to the LGB
Alliance guys and they separate
sexuality and gender so that's part of
the debate you have to parcel out and
the TQ plus might be harbinging
something more Insidious and I said have
you heard of Gail Rubin and before I
finished my thought an inspector who had
been bused in from from Kent to
Birmingham which is you know cancer
South Birmingham to the north that's
where the conference was run up to me
waved his finger in my face um he had to
go on his tiptoes because he's rather
short and he said to me right
um if you continue this conversation on
warning you I will arrest you under the
public order offense bill because you've
insulted This Woman's sexuality because
he'd overheard the word Insidious not
overheard the conversation properly and
he just said do you understand what I'm
saying and when I try to clarify and ask
my questions he said this is not about
questioning I'm telling you what's
happening here I got surrounded by 10
other police officers arms folded
riddled to tackle me and one guy had a
shoulder mounted camera recording the
entire thing and what they do in the UK
is if you are reported for like an
offense but it's not criminal offense
you'll be registered on the non-crime
hate incident registry which means
there's a black mark against your name
that you never know exists and if
employers do a background check on you
even if you have been commonly charged
that will come up and you will be turned
down for jobs without ever knowing it so
I I had to rely on some a lovely
gentleman by the name of Harry Miller he
support for fair cop now
um bad law project and he he got
confirmation that I wasn't in that
registry we filed a complaint to the
police but it went nowhere because they
protect their own and so yeah England's
England's undoubtedly a very uh
Progressive captured country can I ask
you do you feel like there's a cultural
difference in the different regions like
Northern England has a different
attitude towards these things than maybe
the South because that's what I feel is
at least The Stereotype in America that
we're very regionally divided uh you'll
hear West Coast versus you know
conservative Texas perhaps uh we have
something called the red wall in England
and that was created because when
Margaret Thatcher was in power she
decided to disband in industries that
she thought were defunct mainly things
like coal mining and they had been
long-standing sources of community
wealth since generational prosperity for
years even though they weren't
generating as much and when she ripped
that out um she did a lot of battle with
the unions as well and so that's that's
made them more union-ish and so they
voted labor as as a part of their
identity she didn't really replace it
with anything and so up north
um you know there's a north-south
antagonism they they we call them
Northern monkeys they call us Southern
pufters and we get along with a bit of a
bit of solidarity against against any
other country that wants to try their
luck
um but they have resentment of the South
South because they see Politics as too
centralized in the South and they see it
as they left them behind and this was
the big difference of Boris Johnson 2019
as well because the north overwhelmingly
voted for brexit thinking that we're
sending too much money over to the
European Union it could be reinvested
here and Boris Johnson said right if you
guys let me Evo I'll do that I'll do a
program called leveling up which
basically means you'll get new rail
infrastructure you get new job
opportunities with the regional
investment and the Northerners voted for
him and then they voted obviously for
Boris because they they liked him on
character you know he used to be the
London mayor he got stuck on a zip line
he'd wave little Flags he was like Mr
Bean you know people people thought it
was fun um then covert hit lockdowns
happened we were imprisoned in our home
for multiple years and Boris who
professed to be a Libertarian squandered
all the money away on that and then
started partying while we were all
locked in our homes and that all got
leaked and it was a big yeah I've heard
about this the the league of political
leaders partying in England what is the
Fallout from that ban uh Boris Johnson
got scapegoated from it Matt Hancock who
was the health secretary who was having
an affair with one of his aides at the
time that was called on CCTV
um he lost his job but he really needed
a Social distance well yeah I mean um if
you if anyone ever sees a photo of Matt
Hancock I I feel deeply ashamed because
he was doing better with his love life
under lockdown than I do and he is not a
good looking bloke
um but he hasn't lost his place in the
party like Boris Johnson's basically
just been kicked out the commons his
seat is up for re-election um on the GB
News host Lawrence Fox is currently
running in that so I wish him luck but
he really was the scapegoat I mean they
said everything was his fault and I feel
like from my observational standpoint
the party sort of let him uh pay for
their sins yeah take the fall yeah and
and all of the health Executives that
got all the calls around got knighthoods
um Gavin Williamson he was the education
secretary who repeatedly locked down
schools but despite being campaigned not
to
um he resigned from his post for a
particular reason that doesn't come to
mind right now but he resigned in
disgrace and then got a Knighthood from
it it's like they're just buying
people's silence what's the what's the
neighborhood do uh it's just a title
which confers upon you the sort of you
have been endorsed by this do you get
money for it or anything are you really
stipend no no I don't think can you like
kick people off of their land or any of
that crap no I don't think you get any
titles but it's based
Boris kept trying to appoint his dad a
member of the House of Lords repeatedly
and remember she didn't shut that down
but but that's absolutely to your point
Rishi sunak is the prime minister right
now he wasn't elected like the when
Boris went the members chose Liz trust
now Liz truss is dim as a two what bulb
she's she's not great but she was too
dumb to be on side of the global project
what we have is a bit of split in the
conservative party right now with the
neocons they both share goals on Ukraine
but for different reasons um the neocons
are more Cold War the global faction are
more like we want to line blackrock's
Pockets
um Liz truss was filming in the neocon
camp and she wanted to Major League well
not major minely cut taxes right British
and that was a tax and spend guy um he
was the guy that printed all the money
as Chancellor during covid he did he did
the equivalent to stimulus packages
let's bankrupted the country um but they
spun the narrative as to where it's only
Ukraine and the pandemic it wasn't what
she soon next for the members voted for
this truss overwhelmingly Liz Tross gets
in and she's the shortest serving prime
minister in history because she wanted
to do what a one percent tax car and she
announced it on a Monday the bank of
England uh the the published that sort
of stats on the guilt Market on the
Friday and the News didn't hit till the
Monday and it coincided with the fact
the bank of England realized they'd run
out of money so they useless trust his
policy as a scapego and we know this
because like Rishi senek immediately
started spending more money and this
suddenly wasn't going to break the
market how weird and so they got their
man in they got them in by the back door
despite him being utterly complicit in
in the parties and the economic damage
done under the pandemic thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time